so we're demoing here seeing VR which is
a tool set of about 14 tools that we
developed to make virtual reality
accessible for low vision people people
with low vision more than 200 million
around the world are people that suffer
from deficits and visual that cannot be
fixed with glasses and they could enjoy
a lot from environments such as virtual
reality that could be set to fit their
needs
however most application nowadays are
not well suited for low vision people
and there's many reasons for that one of
them is that there's a large variety of
different effects at low people low
vision people are suffering from whether
it is blurring or sensitivity to light
or low contrast or a limited field of
view and trying to answer everyone which
is a very difficult task so what we try
to do is to come out with a set of tools
that will be really easy to use for the
developers to add them to whatever game
or application that they have or that
can be added from outside to an existing
application and that the user could turn
on and off different features according
to her need so let's say that I'm right
now looking at some off the web video
game where you are doing a quest you're
going into some rooms looking for
objects and trying to find clues to
proceed further now for the atmosphere
of the game many designers will put a
lot of objects in they will have maybe a
dark environment a lot of similar color
textures and it's hard for someone with
low vision to really detect the objects
of interest so we can have this gallery
of tools starting from very similar
simple tools like a magnifying glass
minute yes a magnifying glass that
enables me to read the larger text
rather than the original text was
further away or maybe I have a
segmentation of objects though I could
easily see that this candle is different
from the floor or that if I go over here
there's a book and a pillow on the table
people that might have limited field of
view can see different views that can
help him
whether it is an overview there's
something there on my left or a guide
lines like these are the objects that I
need so I can just follow my guide line
and I will get into each one of the
objects and by the way even people
without with full vision don't see
behind their back so they can enjoy such
functionality we can have a changing of
contrast to make it clearer we can find
only objects that are important for the
story versus maybe that candle here is
not important but this one is because
you need to go through the door which
highlight you and and and so on it's and
all the way to cognition services to
recognize if there's known objects in
the game or even have Mechanical Turk
help to help people navigate into the
environment and we hope such tools we
can help people not just for gaming also
for productivity applications to use
very large display that virtual reality
enables you to do without having to get
too close to the screen and also enjoy
the fact that they have a screen display
which is really close to the eye which
many people describe as helpful for them
as well as the application will be
better fit for them now
you